mir grande production américaine à
choisir notre île pour décor un vrai
film d'action et de guerre l'histoire
d'un soldat des forces spéciales devenus
mercenaires engagés pour retrouver une
journaliste
au départ le film devait être tourné en
birmanie où se situe l'action mais la
birmanie a fermé ses portes suite à la
crise qu vide et il a fallu trouver un
autre lieu si l'équipe a fini par
choisir la réunion c'est grâce aux
contacts et le travail acharné de
producteurs réalisateurs locaux
le financement de la région a aussi été
une incitation le réalisateur santiago
madness morena serait même très pressé
d'arriver à la réunion est de repérer
les lieux de tournage alors vous aurez
peut-être l'occasion de croiser dans les
semaines à venir links les l'inoubliable
interprète de gandhi lee pierce un autre
acteur à la filmographie impressionnante
dont le rôle du méchant dont iron man 3
ou encore matthew partenaires de jackie
chan dans le tour du monde en 80 jours
la réunion ça fientes depuis quelques
années comme terre de tournages en
accueillant des productions françaises
sa renommée est aujourd'hui prête à
dépasser les frontières
[Musique]